make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so get me back into Shazam this is
our this is our DC video for the day
getting it of Shazam part 3 again this
really kind of focuses on the funds and
the introduction of the introduction
introducing the introduction of of King
kit again one of the things to remember
this we talked about that in the first
two videos is that this is basically a
continuation of Geoff Johns Shazam run
in the backup feature of Justice League
when the new 52 first launched and where
the the Shazam family had essentially
like gone to the rock of eternity found
an empty and then found basically this
giant map of the magic lands this is the
first place they visited now again this
is world building by Geoff Johns it's
expanding things out and so king kid is
this this kid literally who rules over
the fun lands where's a place where
children who feel kind of cast off or
feel like they don't really have a place
can essentially go now there is kind of
a caveat to this and we'll get to that
more once we go through it but it's
basically kind of a Neverland thing now
a little bit of sidetrack here I heard
this theory once about Peter Pan that
the way Neverland work is it was
actually a place for kids who died that
like whatever they died Peter Peter Pan
would show up and he would wish them off
to Neverland which is basically heaven
and like they would spend the rest of
their lives there which really kind of
flies in the face of everything that was
my childhood and totally turns Peter Pan
on its head um it's kind of crazy like
it's kind of messed up yeah like I've
heard was like really there's some
really dark theories about Peter Pan to
you but nonetheless this is kind of a
cool thing because this place is just
like a giant it's a giant amusement park
is really what it is there's there's
like 300 some odd rides here and there's
a ton of different things to do but for
the most part where most of the members
of the Shazam family are kind of like
rolling on with it and just like hey
yeah let's have fun here Mary Marvel is
the one person who doesn't really go on
with it now again Mary marvel over the
years has kind of been depicted as hey
like like kind of the mom of the group
if that makes any sense you know where
she's kind of the one that makes sure
that like everybody kind of does what
they're supposed to do and everybody's
kind of in check and all the kind of
cool stuff and so she's the one you know
getting ready to turn 18 she's the one
who's kind of like look we should
probably be asking some questions here
like we shouldn't just be like rolling
with it now in the defense of the Shazam
family and I'm sure like a lot of you
guys would agree if you suddenly found
yourself in a place where there was just
like nothing but amusement parks and
like candy and like soda and all that
kind of stuff I would go with it I would
just be like okay so like I'm not
leaving here like this this because
here's the thing guys like fun land it
looks like the most fun ever like it
looks it looks like the most fun you
could possibly have and like I would
stay like I would just be like okay
whatever let's just roll with it but we
kind of get this
of king Kidd and the idea behind this
was that he was basically a kid who had
like really cruel parents and
essentially just like ran for his life
one day after his parent after his
father was like abusing him and
basically kind of like stumbled over
over a tree trunk and then fell into
this place we was just like this giant
empty land were like some of the rivers
tasted like milk now here's the funny
thing about this is that unlike billy
batson
you know who was like whisked away by
the wizard Shazam and then given the
whole thing this we told about like the
nature of the powers and so on and so
forth and then told when he shouts his
namesake the he'll basically have like
all these different abilities instead
like king kid just showed up there but
the funny thing about it is that it
seems like because he was the first
occupant he's basically the one whereby
the lands basically do whatever is it he
wants them to do and so essentially like
he wished well he just kind of imagined
that there would be a cure cell and
suddenly there was one that was there
and as time progressed all these
different kids kept showing up now when
I say time progressed I mean in a matter
of hours these kids just kind of started
showing up here so it's kind of an
interesting scenario where like all it
took was one person to kind of imagine
gaining access to it and then suddenly
everybody was able to to like go on
board with it now the cool thing about
this is that what King kid and really
what like Mary Marvel and the other
members basically say is like with all
these different lands these different
territories it really kind of seems to
be like a hands-off situation right like
the man I'm sorry that the fun lands are
isolated from like the wild lands or
like the game lands or anything like
that you know it's almost kind of like
Secret Wars from 2015 well they're all
basically cut off and separated from one
another so it's almost like a little
like a miniature multiverse inside an
existing universe it's kind of cool you
know it's pretty cool to see it unfold
that's one of the big things that kind
of goes on is because when when Billy
Batson and then basically say well hey
man it's been fun
but it's kind of time for us to go King
kid begins asking questions like why
would you want to leave which really
kind of indicates the fact that like you
can't they're like once you're there you
can never leave you can never get away
now for the most part it seems to kind
of solve itself right like most kids who
show up here don't really want to leave
anyway and so if there's no reason to
kind of bring in the question like what
happens when you try to get away but for
Billy in them like they're like what we
want to leave and basically King kid
says like no you can't because they live
with their parents of that kind of stuff
they kind of showed up here outside of
the normal circumstance and so literally
like Billy's Billy's like take it away
like like I'm sorry like Darla and
Freddy and then like marry like they're
basically like yanked away as it was
kind of a crazy thing because in
response to that Billy shouts the power
shouts the word Shazam the Shazam family
turns into the superhero counterparts
and that's work working kid begins to
freak out
basically say like you're all Liars here
like you've all basically tricked us
you've all duped us now
again very Neverland like with regards
to this whole situation right like the
only adults who exist in Neverland are
pirates and they're bad guys and so it's
it's kind of cool how this whole theme
plays out borrowing very heavily from
like other forms of literature which is
par for the course when it comes to
comics I mean after all in 2019 there
really is no such thing as like an
original idea so it is it is kind of
cool to see this whole thing play out
because of Shazam family while they're
not really fighting to kill they're
basically fighting to try to like save
their friends and like along the way
when they're trying to get to these
various members of the of the like
Shazam family you're thrown like
literally they're throwing like these
different locations into these different
parts of a fun land so it's not as
though King kid is trying to like kill
them it's basically like you're banished
from this place like get out of here
like we're throwing you out and so what
what is up happening here is different
members of the Shazam family in Devon
different places some end up in the game
lands which is like a giant video game
place which is kind of cool there's like
a little WB symbol right there which is
kind of interesting but like they
they're literally in like the in like
the game lands which is like a giant
video game like world which I'm pretty
hyped about and then there's also like
the wild lands which is like where the
animals reign supreme it's a cool little
set of events here like it's a cool
little bit of a story here and that's
one of the things that kind of bear in
mind when it comes to this whole Shazam
series that's being created by Geoff
Johns is this basically kind of building
on everything that we've seen before
that's one of the important things when
it comes to the Shazam family they've
been around for a very very very long
time and so when you had like you know
earth s which was their alternate
reality where they resided you know it
was really kind of congealed keeping
their stories contained there before the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths but
post crisis when there was no multiverse
there really wasn't a whole lot you
could do when the multiverse came back
things were still kind of being still
kind of in fluctuation but there wasn't
a whole lot of like alternate reality
Shazam development going on there what
this does is expand things out in an in
a pretty big way and that's what geoff
johns does that's the nature of geoff
johns storytelling the nature of geoff
johns storytelling is to look at a
particular character or a particular
team and then build on that existing
content right like we've seen that with
green lantern that's one of the big
things that people kind of hit on you
know that then when it came to the Green
Lantern mythos originally there was just
the Green Lantern Hal Jordan and then
that turned into like the Sinestro Corps
and that turned into like the red
lanterns and the Indigo tribe and the
star sapphires and the black Lancers and
the white lanterns and like oh you know
the blue lanterns and all these
different things is the same thing with
the flash mythos right you know the same
thing with it with the flash concept
they're like well you did have all these
speed
it was grabbing all the other speedsters
building on the work of Mark Waid with
like terminal velocity the concept of
the speed force and then just kind of
going forward from there now the
question to ask here is like what
follows this and of course the next one
is basically called like this secretive
king kid but again like they're all kind
of showing over these different areas
different locations so it's kind of the
question like what comes next but one of
the things that King kid basically hit
on here and it's kind of an important
thing is that like this Shazam family
we're supposed to have a seventh member
and King kid basically says like I'm the
seventh person who's supposed to be part
of the Shazam family but more so than
that what's supposed to happen is
presumably the different members of the
Shazam family are going to be like
overseers for the magic lands that like
each realm will basically have like a
guardian and where King kid sees himself
is like the king of the fun lands you
know he'd be the one to watch over that
as a seventh member of the Susann family
and then Billy Batson Mary Marvel and
everybody else Darla and all them they
would basically go through and like like
Freddy and so on they would each
safeguard one particular realm of the
magic land so again like it's kind of
cure it's kind of interesting to see
like where it goes from here and I'm
really kind of curious to see like how
it all unfolds us that's kind of the
funny that's that's the question to ask
because I feel like this will turn into
like a war of the Shazam family or like
a war like we basically have like all
these realms kind of fighting against
each other we're not not a hundred
percent sure I don't really know if Jeff
Jones would go in the direction of like
DC or of like Marvel's war of realms it
would seem to too extreme but but again
like in reality none of these worlds
really seem ominous and that's what kind
of that's what kind of makes it cool is
because this Shazam titled by and large
while it has had a has had a history of
like some darker stories right like the
power of Shazam run where it has had
like the other Shazam stories over the
years which were kind of darker
especially when it came to like dr.
sivana what John's really constant it
kind of seems to be doing is building
the Shazam mythos as if it's more base
are really more rooted for like
attraction to children we just say like
kids can dig it as opposed to like
adults it's kind of cool because I mean
like as an adult like I still like it
like I think it's kind of cool you kind
of get the best of both worlds but it
doesn't really see where they're gonna
end up in a realm where like people are
being like massacred or anything like
that like oh he's gonna be that dark you
know for the most part it's still pretty
light-hearted now whether or not it
stays that way we don't know that's kind
of the question to ask here but in any
event we have being said guys we really
gotta bring this video to an and sort of
ramble for the latter half of the video
but I don't think anybody Minds that
much if you are new here to comment
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video
make
you drop a lake and I will catch you all
later purse
[Music]